[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
valentina qui aidera tous très émus on
la comprend nous on est aussi aimé carla
[Applaudissements]
c'est ou face à alexandra super alors
avec sandra raid c'est celle que
j'appelle très souvent pour parler des
programmes de france télévisions alors
mais c'est magnifique c'est magnifique
je suis ravi d'être là et on est ravi de
fêter cette victoire avec vous parce que
vous avez été là vous nous avez soutenu
c'était important pour nous de tout cela
plus dire non chérie tu te rends compte
je rends compte ou pas les adultes ils
n'arrivent jamais à gagner l'eurovision
tokyu l'a fait gagner c'est bon on peut
pas l'envoyer à l'eurovision normal
aussi
non sans rigoler valentina tu t'y
attendais ou pas pour moi c'est tous les
candidats avaient leur chance ils
avaient tous des chansons magnifiques
donc et gt gt surprise mais j'étais
tellement heureuse est à gagner avec 200
points devant le kazakhstan est vrai
kazakhstan sur les toits qu'ils allouent
un final cela tu vois mon frère tu
manges il est sympathique joie france
kazakhstan ça change un peu et moi
j'étais encore france espagne et j'adore
mois la formule de leurs opinions nord
j'aime bien là c'est très fort et ma
chérie je voulais dire franchement je
pense tu vas être une énorme star cela
fait longtemps qu on la reçoit sur le
plateau et ça fait six mois on l'a reçu
à déterminer et à l'école aujourd'hui
non non tu vas y retourner contre me
retourner demain non mais tu te rends
compte à l'école je vais arriver avait
prévenu tous tes copains et tous que tu
essaies l'eurovision junior oui mes
meilleurs amis ajoutait au courant c'est
ton plus beau souvenir parce que déjà à
ton âge alors on va rappeler ton âge
cestac et là je m'incline à terme 11 3
11 ans et on parce que déjà à son âge
elle a une carrière de ouf et à la plus
de carrière que nous tous sur mamy
calais par le couple c'est là que je
vais m
ce mail à tous mes frères à libé elle
est sympathique et d'abus comme la
sportivité
oui toutes les chansons étaient man où
j'en étais devant les gens non le reste
est de la mer c'est normal tu gagnes tu
viser le top 5
oui c'est vrai je j'espérais évidemment
de gagner après je m'y attendais je m'y
attendais tellement pas cg on a un trou
c'était un vrai bloc
oui tes parents restée comme des fous
oui à fond il mes parents mes parents
aussi
ils voulaient pas créer victoire trop
vite et qu'il faut avant pour pas que tu
sois déçu tandis qu avant qu'ils et
elles m'ont dit que quoi qu'il arrive
c'était une très belle expérience
tu aurais été déçu si tu avais terminé
voilà aussi 7e
non parce que bah si ça reste quand même
une aventure extraordinaire
tu étais heureuse de représenter la
france était important pour toi un très
heureux très fier des filles comme elle
est belle je te jure
alexandra alors pour vous et c'est
exceptionnel c'est la première fois
alors vous vous n'avez jamais gagné
l'eurovision nicolas pernikoff qu'on se
détient directement
je vais vous dire un truc moi j'ai pensé
alexandra parce que c'est quand on est
patron des divertissements à france
télévision je crois que le grand kiff et
le grand rêve c'est de gagner
l'eurovision qui est quand même l'un des
plus beaux spectacles au monde et un des
plus chers ce qui est impossible pour
des raisons stratégiques s'est vite
quand on passe dans les animaux de l'ami
donc du coup quand je les ai vus j'ai vu
avec sandra qui était qui et avec elle
est folle de joie parce que c'est
vraiment un moment incroyable à vivre le
jeu vous rappelle que l'eurovision c'est
le spectacle télévisé le plus cher du
monde
mais je sais alors on va le voir le
l'organiser l'année prochaine avec
sandra et ben on a envie de l'organe ans
et ça va coûter cher cet aspect cette
affaire on doit parler à l'eurovision
allure là dans les prochains jours donc
on va savoir comment tout ce que se
mettre en place mais on a envie de le
faire delphine ernotte a envie de le
faire stéphane sitbon aussi et ça serait
merveilleux de pouvoir accueillir cet
événement je vais dire aux
téléspectateurs moi j'ai commenté deux
fois l'eurovision records d'audience à
leur hobby
avec vos conneries là avec nicolas
pernikoff on a fait combien 6 millions
3,6 millions téléspectateurs donc lui
est alors à 3,8 en france est lourde et
103 d'étagères sans confinement sans
rien on était tous dehors il y en avait
cinq millions chute avec style
j'ai pris avec julien combes et on a
bien fermer notre gueule on était dans
une cabine de 1 mètre carré je me tenir
prêt à fermer nos gueules mais on n'a
pas demandé notre est alors les chéris
non et moi je vous jure que c'est vrai
j'étais avec la délégation française et
ils nous ont dit la meilleure place
c'est deuxième ou troisième pour que on
se prennent au jeu jusqu'à la fin mais
si on arrive premier va nous coûter une
tonne organiser l'année prochaine parce
que j'avais été en russie par exemple il
a émis 30 2 millions d'euros pour la
soirée
voilà donc avec sandra est ce que c'est
vrai que on n'a pas très envie
l'eurovision junior o'keefe le gagner
l'eurovision normal on aime bien être
bien placé mais le gagner c'est quand
même une petite année tout à fait il
faut réfléchir ça c'est cela notre ça
coûte très cher non mais c'est vrai
regain d'aversion pour les moteurs des
chars effectivement donc c'est pour ça
que l'eurovision julien on est plutôt
content mais je sais que vous êtes vous
waterfall eurovision aussi vous avez
envie d'avoir un bon candidat cette
année aussi
oui et je sais que vous avez envie de la
gagner vous quoi qu'il arrive on ce
challenge voilà est en vie mais c'est
votre plus beau souvenir depuis que vous
êtes à france télé ou pas c'est un
souvenir qui sera inoubliable
parce que en fait ça fait 43 ans que la
france n'a pas gagné l'eurovision c'est
un moment on se dit toujours est ce
qu'on peut y arriver vraiment à le
gagner ou est-ce que c'est finalement
tout s'est très utopique et quand on
arrive et que d'un coup on se dit on se
regarde avec val n est qu on se dit
quand on est plus que deux dans les
écrans est ce que c'est possible qu'on
le fasse et on entend moins urgents
entendu et docks la veut dire quoi en
france et donc là à ce moment là on se
dit vraiment que c'est un point à un
moment unique et julien tri série je te
d'autres séries les un truc important
c'est que c'est comme toi si une
histoire de famille l'eurovision et je
trouve que c'est vraiment important de
le souligner de le remercier parce qu'il
ya toute la délégation française france
télévision et tout le monde et vous
savez qu'on est dans un moment de crise
sanitaire qui est juste dingue et que de
mettre ce petit moment de bonheur
surtout qu'on a gagné
valentina tu te rends compte ou pas tu
seras toujours saillie toi avis tu auras
gagné l'eurovision tard palmarès
tu vois ce qu'on a personne ici paul
choppin souvenirs incroyables en plus
quand ils ont annoncé les résultats mois
moi j'ai pas entendu en fait le chiffre
et j'ai juste vu n'attend d'ailleurs que
je remercie car là aussi tous les kids
on est toujours à fond derrière moi et
je vois nathan sauter partout et j'en
suis dit bon moi je crois que voilà et
ben hebert syrie et par le public en
plus immersive à l'unanimité merci
madame merci avec ça